alright time once again for the movie
retrospective we're doing a double
feature today that's right this is we're
gonna commemorate the beginning of the
satanic panic movies like these that
actually started the satanic panic this
is what brought it up where everybody is
everywhere yeah this is this probably
contributed this was yeah these two
movies The Exorcist man just Amityville
Horror and just you know Rosemary's Baby
I really loved the whole satanic yeah
maybe Shatner did we seriously have to
do shadow did a satanic movie I can't it
was well it was fun in a cheesy way and
you got to see Ernest Borgnine Goathead
that's how I didn't really watch it that
closely I just remember rolling my eyes
at it but I'm sure Volta was in it to
you but you wouldn't recognize him
unless you were looking for I didn't see
Shatner's one back in the day I saw that
one just more recently so I'd have to
get into that seventies mood to say to
see it in its context but these two
movies here actually are real good ones
yeah they're blanks good forgotten ones
and they're both on shudder right now
yeah and that's why we decided to do
both because I'm like hey these are both
through the 70s
they're both um they both kind of
concern vehicles and they're both like
satanic so I said so it's like a satanic
vehicular manslaughter double feature
we're doing the car yeah and race with
the devil yeah and they're both restored
they look they're look they look really
good the soundtracks are good they are
movies of their times I don't I don't
remember what was called race with the
devil I don't remember that one but from
my childhood but I remember the car yeah
yeah all the kids at school were talking
about it that was about seventh grade I
think when that yeah yeah I came out in
1970 yeah and all my friends were just
talking about you know the car
this devil car and I didn't get to see
it I mean yeah so I just had to imagine
it for a couple years maybe a year and
then they showed it on television it was
it every
you hoped it would be and more yeah yeah
back in those days but it looks even
better in HD like it would like it was
supposed to look on the big screen yeah
because it looked like a cheap
made-for-tv movie when I saw it on tell
everything did but it's like I'm really
glad that they're restoring a lot of
these movies from the 70s it's very high
quality movie for the time yeah they
actually look so much better than you
know you even like when we saw them on
cable or when we saw them like shitty
VHS yeah you know but now they they look
all and you can see like the good
cinematography they actually did know
what they were doing I guess we'll start
off with the car yeah we're gonna start
with the car even their race with the
devil came out first but I think the
cars gonna be better better known I
think yeah so people watching this
retrospective are probably probably to
watch it for to see the review of the
car I mean I was wondering if this is
where Stephen King got the idea for
Christine I think so although a lot of
that living car movies and possessed car
movies this was the first one I remember
and they there was other ones there was
other like kind of killer car movies in
the 70s that was dual
that came out in 1971 and that was based
on an older like Richard Matheson yeah
but this was Satan in it trail it was
also death race 2000 that came out yeah
Satan wasn't 1975 but yeah so this one
they decided we're gonna take like the
killer car genre and cross pollinate it
with you the satanic cult yeah and it
worked if you ask me it worked and when
the movie starts you'll hear sound the
song and you can tell that Kubrick
ripped this song off for the shiny sea I
wanted to know about this because like
not so much as the song goes on but the
opening theme for the car yeah sounds
almost exact it's like I think it sounds
like an oboe but it just has like
wah-wah wah-wah kind of thing yeah at
the beginning of the shining and I'm
like riff and it's not the same composer
because we looked it up yeah so now I'm
kind of wondering how did that happen
yeah it's not exactly the same but it's
very similar and the movies balls to the
walls I mean there's no explanation or
anything it just starts off with this
spooky ass [ __ ] music it's like from
The Shining we don't recognize it
immediately car coming out of the damn
tunnel running over a cute girl within
the first few minutes Anna boy it's
Santa boy yeah you got see it doesn't
run over him necessarily but it like
yeah kind of pushes him there on
bicycles and they're riding along and
said this was filmed it looked like in
California Utah somewhere like you can
say yeah parts of Kay I think parts of
it were filmed in Utah - but yeah so
that's how it opens up it's like this
new explanation these two like all
American kids are like you know
good-looking and we're yeah ride a bike
down some like remote mountain road and
it's really pretty like the beautiful
scenery and all of a sudden this [ __ ]
car which is like I think it's a Lincoln
Continental but it's I looked it up I
don't think it was um it was heavily
modified yeah why not add a white
widened it they removed a French tin the
bumpers put different bumpers on it
lowered the top they drop the top and
they put like matte paint on it and that
black no door handles no outer controls
it's just a for the in you know for the
day it was a [ __ ] wicked looking car
yeah it was kinda it wasn't a muscle car
it was like a lot to do our luxury car
wikipedia says that it was a modified
1971 Lincoln Continental Mark three okay
so it was and that they actually made
four of them yeah because they wrecked
some of them cuz they wrecked three of
them yeah and one of them was like for
close-ups yeah and you can see it
happening sometimes you know they bash
it in the front of it doing an endo you
know right in - yeah drive it too fast
on a bumpy road I saw the the nose dig
in one time have been the the bumper
into an angle yeah the next shot it was
repaired again yeah but yeah they were
breaking those cars well yeah that's why
that doesn't many so like I said they
had four of them like modded out one of
them they didn't wreck and I think it's
at a private collection somewhere the
other three they did wreck American
tunnel yes somebody lucked out so
somebody's running around running people
over for
no good reason and the local cops get
involved and it's kind of like kind of
like you know California desert area you
know like in this year outside the
Sierra Nevada
you know the Sierra Nevada is actually
very desert II you know and I used to go
there as a kid and of course you know
they got Native Americans on the police
force too and there are so many Pete I
don't know how big this town is I don't
remember what town it's supposed to be
there are so many cops in this town yeah
what that's about normal well I guess so
different shifts and yeah that was like
well that's I liked that about this
movie because I said you know a lot of
movies from the 70s especially if it's
set about yeah it's like two cops and
it's like oh man there's like all these
murders we don't know but this actually
showed there was like a dozen cops yeah
and the whole force yeah it was like a
whole force oh dude that was like a
realistic yeah in its favor cuz I don't
usually see that and of course one it
focuses in on the most is the young Burt
Reynolds knockoff cop who of course is
the dude from mu or is James Brolin
James Brolin and he [ __ ] knocks it
out of the park in the 70s yeah he
knocks it out of the park and in this
one there's a lot of like 70s faces that
you know in this and the town drugs and
wifebeaters and you instantly recognize
the guy who played the head of OCP at a
[ __ ] Robocop one yeah what was his
name he also he wasn't in ships was he I
don't think he was in ships in fact the
first time we watched this because I saw
this when I was a kid and then I didn't
see it again but then when it came up on
shudder the car I'm racing the devil
came up on shudder like the same day and
I was like oh man that's what we're
doing so so I'm watching it the first
time I rewatched it the little girls
that's in it cuz James Brolin is in it
and he has two daughters and I guess
he's like a widower he's divorced or
something like that but he has custody
of his two daughters now one of the
daughters the first time I watched this
and you'll back me up on this I'm like
is that [ __ ] Holly from landed alive
look like it it is not however I know I
knew that I knew those two little girls
now those two little girls I look this
[ __ ] up that are sisters in real life
their names are Kim and Kyle Richards
now Kyle who I
I was the older one she was in Halloween
she was also an eaten alive the tobe
Hooper movie and she had a recurring
role on Little House on the Prairie
which is probably I recognize her matter
from Halloween
now Kim who I think is the younger one
no she was the older one I recognized
her from escape from Witch Mountain she
was also in assault on precinct there
precinct 13 she was the one yes she was
the little girl that the gang members by
the ice cream truck that they shot okay
that was her younger in that one yeah
now fun fact those two sisters are now
on Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
which you wouldn't really reckon we're
when I saw it and at first I thought is
that that's the chick Melinda laws right
I'm like God where I'm where have I seen
her yeah but yeah so escape from Witch
Mountain was where I neither one from
but I had seen the other one in
Halloween and stuff like yeah it's a fun
fact but yeah but this movies a good
movie the tone of the movie there's
something about this movie that kind of
reminds me of gargoyles remember the
movie cars yeah yeah yeah the executions
a lot better and it doesn't rely on
gargoyle costumes or anything it relies
on this car the car is the monster yes
paranormal and it can do a lot of cool
[ __ ] it can ramp through a house six
feet off the ground so it can kind of
jump itself yeah it can teleport it can
silently appear in your garage when your
back does a lot of cool [ __ ] and you
know there and there's when I was a kid
you stripped me out because they were
always trying to look into the car and
and there's a scene where the door pops
open and Brolin can look in and he sees
something remember that yeah and you
know you want to know what the devil
looks like they never show it to you
nobody asks him later on what you seen
you guys nothing I didn't see nothing
yeah now you don't know anything about
it though is that an interesting thing
about this car maybe this was done for
budgetary reasons but they never I don't
think they ever really come out and say
that it's the devil in the car really I
mean now there's a quote from Anton
LaVey at the beginning of this movie and
apparently Anton LaVey was kind of a
a consultant on this movies yeah that's
some money right right right
so but I don't know like they say stuff
like like dude that was in [ __ ]
debate the movie with the banjos what
the [ __ ] is the name of that movie why
can't I remember it with the banjo
you know the rape the Ned Beatty rape
movie oh you talking about squeal like a
pig yeah it was the name of that would
not [ __ ] now you got me now you got any
damnit about yeah I haven't even drunk
that much and I can't [ __ ] remember
[ __ ] whatever
deliverance Miller thank you mad cow
disease it's a touch of the mad cow but
yeah so dude from deliverance now he
says that he figures out that the car
can't go on hallowed ground and they
start to suspect that there's something
supernatural going on because like they
shoot at it and it doesn't make any
dancer it doesn't flatten the tires um
you know what I mean just [ __ ] like that
the car also knows things it can't know
like it knows where people live yeah
anytime
it's a spiritual force it can teleport
yeah Brolin walked into his mother
doesn't do it all the time
Brolin walked into his garage the garage
door was shut
he goes up to I forgot me it's good you
got something out of the tool [ __ ]
yeah turned around in the cars there
tada oh [ __ ] he's like go away you know
shut the door leave look what is it you
need justice go go go cuz back in the
70s and then something's wrong you
didn't tell a woman yeah you just might
go do you just yeah we just left us the
[ __ ] was going on no one would tell us
[ __ ] was funny man because Bros was
walking around in that damn moustache
and Jeanette cop outfit you know and
he's walking around toughest tough as
nails you know I mean so I can like a
like a Burt Reynolds he takes his shirt
off and a Munford got the arms like that
70s was a different era you could just
act like a badass and get away with it
back in the 70s yeah we were talking
about that yeah that was like that was
pre Arnold Schwarzenegger well it was
kind of like and I think we might have
mentioned this to you when we were
talking about Charlton Heston yeah you
know what I mean and we were talking
about him and not yeah yeah so it's like
they're all like walking around with
their shirts I'm like the 70s
everyone's like yeah throwing their
weight around like they were a massive
350 pound joyous dudes head arms they
just you know like that you know it's
just it's kind of funny how like I said
oh you had Arnold Schwarzenegger change
the world when he showed up you were
like oh yeah that dude they I guess we
change the game change the game well
like I said all you had to do was kind
of act like it you said the act okay to
talk to us yeah Benny right like if you
it flew oh yeah seventies people like oh
yeah yeah because I almost armor wasn't
around yeah that's as soon as they saw
that they're like oh okay although you
know who I'm gonna I'm gonna pull this
out of my back pocket he was around
during that time Charles Bronson even
though he was a very tall guy he was in
real good shape in some of those movies
yeah Charles Bryant want to Charles
Bronson probably five five actually yeah
I wouldn't [ __ ] with him he was in real
good shape
some of those movies yeah but you know
anyway just get back to uh although
honestly I always liked James roll I
liked him in Amityville Horror yeah yeah
and I liked him in this too and he's you
know I also like his son who has
obviously been in a ton of movies also
including but I can see what you're
saying it's like and I kind of love him
in this because just it's like facial
expression when he turns around of the
[ __ ] car is there yes like it's like
it's kind of like the same facial
expression that's when he looks up and
sees like that yeah the human Pig it was
an era where guys grew beards and
moustaches and we're real serious and
real hard-boiled but they didn't really
have to physically fight anybody and if
they did they they weren't very big well
it is kind of like later you know in the
second movie wasn't Peter Fonda yeah
Peter feel we'll get to that we get the
Peter Fonda was a scrawny son [ __ ] too
well he had a rifle so what's that he
had a rifle in that movie
you didn't need to be you didn't need to
punch people in the face cuz he had a
rifle but yeah I really like this the
great equalizer now it is the devil it
starts off with the devil earlier yeah
it's the devil I mean we've never seen
some kind of a demon has infested yeah I
don't think like I said they don't make
that do see it well you see it at the
very end of the series and it looks like
a snake right the face of a serpent yeah
which you know they're talking about
Satan
yeah it in the in the flames you know
when they just destroy the car but it
know that that's what that was one of
the cool things I'm not gonna spoil
everything you should just move her to
old its old 1977 they blow the corner I
was five they blew the car up in midair
and collapse an entire Ridge because see
there was a wife-beater who had a bunch
of dynamite and he was kind of late did
you ever think you would hear that
sentence he's a wife beater had a buddy
yeah he has a wife beater in the PA but
he redeems he redeems and stuff because
he had a bunch of dynamite it's kind of
seventies logic he's got dynamite and
they blow down an entire mountain well I
guess not really a mountain ridge but a
ridge line down in a crater at like a
can like in a canyon that collapse a
canyon on the car when it's flying up
through the air in midair you know the
candy comes down and metal Hellfire
flies up it's [ __ ] heavy metal is
[ __ ] and then you see the face of this
damn serpent spitting fire and you go
yeah they find that yeah they finally
got it but then real cool ball flash to
Detroit you see the [ __ ] wheels of
that car it's supposed to be LA as
Detroit because they had the GM yeah am
building was there yeah it's just like
driving down the street going I survived
the day you can't kill me by blowing me
yes oh yeah it responds it responds back
in Detroit which makes more sense
because like I said I was reading a
wikipedia breakdown and it said that
some cuts of the film now some cuts
apparently don't have that apparently
some cuts of the film just end with the
explosion and I love the shot of like
all the surviving cops because the car
kills like half the [ __ ] force but
at the end where they do the big
explosion and everything and they're all
like and they all see like the demon
face and the flames are and then I guess
like some cuts of the film end there
but the cut we saw and I presume the cut
that's on blu-ray or whatever that they
have restored actually has another
little scene where with the credits
rolling over it that shows the car yeah
perfectly fine and like tooling down the
street yeah because like evil never dies
yeah it had the car at some badass
aluminum wheels on it aftermarket lumen
wizard like solid drag wheels a holes in
it and you know when you see the car
part when you see the car the car is
pretty cool
yeah for a seventies car you know the
seventies custom car they widened that
car by a foot at least doesn't like
James Brolin James Roland's girlfriend
in this movie yeah calls the car a what
an upside down bathtub
yes yeah she called it an upside down
bet there's we talk about there's some
hoax there's some hot seventies girls in
this too you know all skinny and skanky
with big boobs and [ __ ] I was like
looking I could not get over except and
I now I say this like every time cuz I
grew up in the 70s I remember these
clothes and stuff like that it was a
sight with time it's well I say this
every time I watch moved here in the 70s
it's like how the [ __ ] did they get into
those pants and I wear corsets yeah on a
regular basis so how did they get into
those [ __ ] pants I couldn't get into
this 7yz was another era I mean the
seventies wasn't you had to be like coke
or skinny
Sammy's was a time when like one of the
top number one groupies was a 13 year
old girl named Maddox yeah you've heard
her yeah you shouldn't look 13 but she
was 13
yeah notice like 73 that that's that
that's how wild that time was cuz legit
there's one scene in this where James
Berlin's girlfriend in this movie who is
a teacher played by Kathleen Lloyd and
she is they're doing like a parade or
something and she's like you know
getting the band
they're rehearsing or whatever little
boys Hannah pictures yeah well yeah that
too
but I mean she's wearing these pants and
they're gold I want to say but the pants
in the 70s like I said it would only
work on like Coke or skinny people like
I don't see how a person with any hips
or any weight on them whatsoever would
be able to wear them is a hell of a job
it is but because they come up to your
waist which why timer it in so I don't
know how they actually tapered in over
the waist I mean you have to lay down to
get in them you must have because and
then there's like no like I said you
couldn't have any couch you couldn't
have any nothing nothing nothing they
wore looked good on anyone that had any
weight right no that's what killed me
well okay now that I'm thinking about it
they were so high waisted they had a
long zipper zipper longer than we would
normally so when you unzip them you
could get in but that's that's what they
were doing I just wore long dresses
entities but you were a little kid done
well I was skinny when I was little but
yeah when I got older like I'm like how
the [ __ ] did anybody wear that it's like
it's not only that I'm that like Coke or
skinny but I'm also really I have really
short legs and I'm really short waisted
so a lot of those pants look super weird
you look good on anybody except real
skinny tall that's what I mean you had
to look great on David Bowie there you
go yes Xena pretty much everything
looked great on to you yeah okay yeah
six feet tall at least yeah can we talk
a little bit about though
okay now this movie I love this movie
but it's 70s cheesy it is cheesy as [ __ ]
and honestly James Brolin is good in it
like all the cops don't forget it
and honestly like I said you know they
actually had an actual police force that
was like I don't remember how many cops
there were but there were like a dozen
at least
yeah and they were like there was some
Native American wands it was black guy
that was owned so it was very like
progressive or that was like multi
that's just a saying
it was I'm just saying that's kind of
cool that's the way California was in a
sense and there were so many of them
cops like I said it was wasn't like
small town that's just like one cop
maybe they wanted so many cops just so
they could kill off okay there's a bunch
of the cops ticket well the cops had to
be the main characters because somebody
had to fight the car so whose
responsibility would that fall on right
fall on the cops so you know it's even
like the police chief gets runs out yeah
so the cops are kind of serving as the
red shirts of you know the meanest and
that's why they had that and they all
had their own characters kind of like in
the way the crew of the Nostromo from
alien 1 we're all very good characters
they all had their own yeah you know
care you know their own motivations and
stuff you know I love that movie too but
yeah this is a good movie it was a movie
of its time and there was a lot of 60s
influence in the filming of it you could
tell the cinematography was kind of
sixties you know I have to say though
that light was a good mood what I was
gonna say was that some of the
characters and particularly I'm gonna
say James Roland's girlfriend who's the
teacher and also the guy with the
trombone
yeah side of the room on the side of the
road like outside the wife-beater yeah
this dude who gets killed he's trying to
be funny and I don't know who thought
that was funny it's just it doesn't come
across as like offensive it just comes
across as like what yeah it was a I
think with it and I lived through the
70s I still don't know I think I was
directing or whoever wrote the script or
something was trying to emulate youth
culture of the time and they didn't
really know youth culture of the time
yeah so they were trying to be like
those cool hip kids but again any know
what the [ __ ] that we're talking about
yeah he's like very artificial it's like
here's this random kid he's like funny
and it's well he's like sitting out in
the middle of nowhere on what is clearly
like a sort of like a dirt road or like
a dead-end street in front of like the
wifebeaters house and there's no other
houses there's no other nothing and he's
talking about the girls are gonna pick
him up who is fantasize and
yeah and of veracruz some [ __ ] like that
and then later on he's talking about
shoving a try
the wife beater says I'm gonna shove
that [ __ ] bone up your ass you're gonna
be farting music Freddie whoa
party music oh he's gone and then he's
like wow great idea and he like goes off
on that maybe he was supposed to be like
on acid is a poorly written character
and I have to say to that like I mean
I've seen Kathleen Lloyd and some other
things but she is like totally goofy in
this movie it's like especially in the
one scene where because what happens is
they realize that there's this card they
don't at first know that it's like
supernatural or nothing but like they
know that there's this car going around
like running people over so they're like
hey you know might want to not do that
band practice like outside like you were
planning on doing like for the parade
and the teachers like oh please can't we
please do it he's like well maybe just
do it later and she was like okay so
they do it and then of course the car
shows up and starts chasing them all and
then they all run up into the hills and
they run into this cemetery which is
hallowed ground but they didn't know
that it was supernatural at the time so
they're all like hunkering down behind
the tombstones and they're just all like
why isn't the car coming in here and the
car is just like sitting out there like
you know revving its engine like it's
mad that it can't get in there and then
Kathleen Lloyd's character she like gets
up for and then she starts like taunting
it yeah but the taunts were very strange
it's like I can't wait sure it's like
they were trying to keep it PG yeah
exactly
she wasn't swearing at it she was just
like making these really weird yeah they
were trying to get around swearing
somehow yeah it really did seem like
that so it did seem like she was just
kind of out there goofy like look at you
and you're upside down bathtub oh won't
you come out here she was like that is a
jerk
yes and I'm like
[Music]
may have been PG it probably does
because there wasn't really a lot of
gore it wasn't it wasn't gory or violent
one of the one of the things that I can
knock this movie about though is that
there was when you have the bad guy or
the monster a car
it's basically serving as the shark in
Jaws really it is what the with the car
serving as you have an opportunity to go
mad max on this we have vehicle versus
vehicle combat yeah but they didn't do
that no it would have cost too much they
did that race with the death they did
with race with the devil when you get to
race to the devil in a minute racing the
devil kind of reminded me a lot of Mad
Max want it there's a lot but with
Satanist yeah but another good movie
pretty good movie yeah but on but with
this one they missed that opportunity
just probably wasn't in the budget yeah
but I would have loved to have seen
Brolin on that motorcycle that he did
have yeah fight that damn car yeah you
know from the only thing you got to see
I mean you got to see like the car ran
over some people it ran over history in
space it ran over like people on
bicycles like it was like it would like
push him off it like [ __ ] up that one
girl and like him push that one guy off
the bridge and he fell like however many
feet that was and like a ravine or
whatever but you didn't get to see it
like really engaged in combat with other
cars it's like it was chasing other cars
it was running over people that were in
the road or at one point like spoiler
alert James Berlin's girlfriend gets
killed because she was the one that was
out there in the cemetery going like
steps on her living room yeah so then
she's on the phone gone I think I hear
the engine I'm really scared she's on
the phone with James boy the car goes
beat goes right to the wall right to the
living room and Spa yeah it's pretty
awesome I have to say yeah but like I
said it is kind of cheesy so there's
like some weird but if you're into like
that cheesy 70s thing I think you will
get a lot of enjoyment I'm not a movie
that you put on your you know what I
mean you're getting bad you turn the
lights off you start drinking like we do
yeah
and just relax to have a good time don't
read into it you try to transport
yourself back to another time of the
seventies yeah into a more innocent time
before CG and expensive effects and it's
and it's fun to like kind of mst3k yeah
I don't know I don't know how younger
people really would but you know Gen X
could relate to the nostalgia of this
type of movie yeah you know we were
maybe seven eight when this came out
yeah what year was this again 77 yes I
was seven I was five yeah okay
so I saw it like probably seven years
later I probably sound I was like nine
or ten I'm thinking because I think I
saw it on cable pay channel something
like that at school all the kids were
all the boys were talking about it they
loved this movie like I said I can't
remember when the book of Christine came
out I feel like that was probably in the
early eighties but I feel like Stephen
King bro although dual was probably a
bigger influence yeah I would think even
though I'm pretty sure he wasn't like
satanic or nothing he was just like you
never saw him it was just like a truck
or you just saw his arm this movie kind
of reminds me of a hybrid of duel and
gargoyles yeah you know I mean and maybe
because Brolin's in it maybe like you
know a [ __ ] yes with a little bit of
Satan sprinkled on top yeah
but I'm just I'm saying that there was
nothing in the car I thought because
didn't that other Native American woman
when she was talking to the Native
American cop and then the other girl
that worked in there she said yeah she
said that she saw in there and there
wasn't a driver yeah so the car or the
car itself was a demon of some sort yeah
I believe I wonder what it's like they
don't really grow he's like why the car
just turned up in this town and started
running people over because the devil
that was 70s logic because the devil was
the word one day and he's like I'm gonna
[ __ ] with these people for never easy
rollin right Brolin was shooting at the
car with the three-percent magnum
revolver yeah and he didn't see any
damage yeah he walked up on it in the
end the window rolled down a little bit
I think the car I think the door open
and he ducked in there and they showed
just Berlin's face he's a and it's shut
and then the car took off you know the
door actually like what poopin like
knocked in
down oh yeah that's right and then it
took off right yeah and they asked him
what he saw there was nothing I didn't
see nothing
yeah so I guess there's nothing in the
car yeah lady said right she said that
she'd seen inside the car there was
nothing in there yeah so that's that's
the thing the car itself was some kind
of demon yeah I guess like I said the
devil has a lot of time on his hands so
you know well I don't know it might just
be a demon it looked like a serpent it's
like a demon in trace of demon yeah that
was like his first it's a possessed car
the devil is like telling the like
little trainee demons it's like all
right you take this town over here just
like turn into something scary and like
go [ __ ] those that's the same [ __ ] from
what Christine and Maximum Overdrive
wasn't that a possessed car - yeah
but this truck yeah well no Maximum
Overdrive was possessed everything like
possessed every every car and like
pretty much every mechanical device
because even like Coke machines and [ __ ]
really good you know I mean where's
Christine Christine was possessed but by
car oh dude yeah yes so it wasn't like a
demon right it was just like possessed
by a guy that had owned the card that
was a [ __ ] head so you want to get on
the other one now yeah now let's talk
about race with the devil another in our
vehicular manslaughter
double feature yeah yeah this one came
out in 1975 Peter Fonda is in this Ward
Oates's insula brenes Witt is in this
the whole time we were watching it every
time she did something I'm like Hot Lips
no that was a mass reference for all you
young people so don't you don't know
they well you know that was a good show
yeah and she was it's funny too when you
go back and you look at Loretta Swit you
realize how young she was yeah yeah yeah
so this one is more now I have to say up
the two movies this one is less cheesy I
think I mean it's still cheesy because
it's 70s but I like this one a little
bit better just because from a
moviemaking standpoint it's a more like
tense experience like your characters in
it's a more complicated yeah and it's
more like it has
that like paranoia thing going on like
Rosemary's Baby where it's like you know
the satanic cult in there like
everywhere and like you don't know who
to trust and [ __ ] like that whole town
stone over by saying yeah so I don't
like that's kind of like children of the
corn in a certain way but yeah yeah yeah
so I like that aspect to it cuz it makes
it like creepier because you know you
can imagine yourself being in that same
situation and then you're like [ __ ] man
I can't even like pull over and get a
flat tire fixed and like the oh is this
due to Satanist ooh you know what I mean
it's like that two couples they're from
another area area I think you're
familiar well no they're from San
Antonio San Antonio they own a the two
guys they own like a motorcycle yeah
they're like dealership they're
motorcycle guys yeah they're racing
racing dirt bikes yeah and so they
decide that there's also like an older
guy younger guy dynamic yes to between
the two guys as older guys in his 30s
yeah I used to be as fast as you and I
was young enough that's the [ __ ] we do
you know [ __ ] the older guy he's
gonna start the Lord over you know back
when I was young how the pastor than you
were we're now that was cool even though
I need a hip replaced you yeah so like
what they decide to do so they own a
motorcycle dealership and at the
beginning of the movie they decide
they're gonna take their wives they
bought a big like fancy RV and they're
actually heading toward Aspen Colorado
yeah but they're gonna drive there in
their RV so they're gonna have to stop
and camp along the way yeah the RV takes
you back to the seventies too with all
the damn carpeting and all the drapes
and [ __ ] and how cheap all that [ __ ]
used to look I remember you know my dad
had had one of those things yeah and all
the furnishings in it was [ __ ] cheap
look at you know everything look
everybody everything with everything
looked like [ __ ] in the seventh yeah I
had like something came out of Soviet
Union they're all [ __ ] tacky [ __ ]
colors it's like everything of that
[ __ ] faux wood paneling like there's
it was seeming ugly even the fibers in
the carpet were real plasticky and
everything was just like made of harmful
chemical material even the clothes look
like something came out of North Korea
like a North Korean but yeah well we
talked about this too cuz when i rewatch
the movie because i actually watch this
twice for the show but i was like the
funny thing about it is that I feel like
the RV which was it was vogue right
because no joke like the Madonna song
I'll remember that
but I was like Logan Suzuki must have a
lot to this movie yeah did they like pay
for probably there are a couple seen
it's not super distracting or super
obvious but there's a couple of scenes
where you know like a like another
couple like comes in it's like you check
this out like it's got this that in the
other oh it's going to actually wave
would be demoing the damn bar look at
this and all the storage we have here oh
yeah you know so I was sitting there
going like I'm pretty sure and I think
they were [ __ ] I think Suzuki had
luck doing it - oh these bikes are so
fast nowadays you know yeah yeah boy
they sure are reliable dependable which
is that is like hilarious to me because
I feel like people nowadays that
complain about product placement like in
movies or TV shows do you guys had
nothing on the 70s or late or the early
80s it was like super they were just
like stop in the middle and be like hey
look at this moment and they would spend
like 25 minutes on that yeah even like
that anybody's tempt to hide it
yeah even in television you know like
you can go back to [ __ ] like I Dream
of Jeannie and bewitched you know like
be there I remember just off the top of
my head a B witched episode where Darrin
gets this badass KITT car that had radar
in it and everything like that it and
and they sit there just plug a damn he
was a custom builder got him good a guy
who is in LA who could [ __ ] build an
build [ __ ] prototype cars it was
weird you know it was they called it
radar I don't know if it really was
radar the display was just a bunch of
lights of course something was in front
of you or not
just put a bunch of light bulbs yeah
radar some rubes will think that bubble
car well [ __ ] man like look at in the
50s whole TV shows were sponsored by one
advertiser yeah and they would have like
a whole this whole show sponsored by
Gaines burgers or whatever there's any
more fallout brought to you by General
Atomics
yeah that's what I mean that's why they
make that joke on the because that's
exactly what it was like and so it's
like I said it's not super super bleep
nuclear future is a clean future it's
not super blatant in this movie but it
was amusing enough that I noticed it
because I was like I think this RV
company probably paid for a plug because
they made like comments about that you
see I mean all the [ __ ] that we have in
this man
we're answer that RV although later on
like when they're at an RV park and the
other creepy couple comes in they're you
know just on uninvited and you're like
hey let me paw through your [ __ ] and
they're like looking through there and
they're and they're kind of like
implying Oh ours is way nicer so I don't
know so maybe not but they were the bad
guys though they were seriously everyone
ends up being Satanism yeah but the
thing I like about this movie okay so
the two couples they're like I said
they're heading for Aspen Colorado but
they're dry they have to drive through
Texas first unfortunately and so they
stopped at this random meadow in Texas
where they think nobody is now the wives
are being responsible and they're just
like okay we're going to bed it early or
whatever they're just like sitting and
reading and they just go to bed and then
the two dudes are sitting out front and
they're getting drunk and there is well
yeah yeah so and the wives are like are
you guys ever coming in it's like we
have to drive tomorrow and we're gonna
end up driving cuz you guys are gonna be
hungover and there's like whatever we're
coming in yeah so then like they're
outside drinking and they look across
the meadow and they see like this creepy
tree and everything like that and then
they see these people and robes and then
there's like oh man let's go check that
[ __ ] out maybe it's like hippies or
whatever yeah the older guy goes maybe
there's an orgy gonna have right right
right so they get super excited only get
the binoculars
man so they go over there and check it
out and they're like oh look oh look
titties yeah you know what I mean and
yeah there's a bunch of like hi girls
[ __ ] you know nude or semi-nude dudes
with damn masks on and which is funny
when you see them later on the ad towels
tighter rather necks like case remember
that's it yeah or or maybe they were
tablecloths and well I I feel like it's
funny whenever I see something like that
in a movie like you everybody has to be
in a satanic cult or whatever they're
just like okay well this is kind of a
low-budget movie so everybody just like
bring your own costume so I feel like
most of the actors are like well [ __ ]
man I don't have like a [ __ ] black
robe or nothing like that so they just
grab the [ __ ] it
they grab an Afghan off the back of this
costumes look terrible yeah and then
like stab and there's like oh yeah
fun's over we can't be girls are like
what the hell happened they killed
somebody we got to get the hell out of
here and then they told the cops and
everything then the cops are like all
you didn't see that yeah maybe they're
just drugged and the time the cops are
trying to talk them out of it they're
gaslighting them yeah and they're gonna
know no we know what we saw well the
cops are in on it too we'll see now I I
liked that about it because they go to
these these [ __ ] cops and the the guy
that plays the main cop he's like a
super famous like character after a
camera what his name is but he's in like
every yeah I think he was it he was in
the car too wasn't he might have been
yeah I think he was yeah yeah so the
same actor I was like oh there's yeah
the same actors are in there so they go
to the cop and the cops just kind of
like okay well we're gonna go out there
and see and you know see where it
happened and blah blah blah so they go
out to the site like the following day
when the Sun's up and then there's like
there's blood on the ground he's like
yeah but that could be this that the
other thing that might not be human
blood it could be animal blood there's
like a dead wolf like hanging from it or
dog or whatever like hanging from a tree
and they're like okay well that's weird
right and there's like whatever you guys
in your drugs and whatever
and like I said they're just totally
gaslighting them so peter fonda even
though you need Peter Peter Fox Kinney
Peter Fonda he doesn't tell the other
people what he's doing but he's like
when the cops had their back turned he
like scoops up like a bunch of the blood
and he's like I'm gonna take this to
like a real City
Amarillo and he's like I'm gonna take it
to a lab and have them analyze if this
is human blood were like reporting this
[ __ ] because he did not trust the cops
immediately because afterward he said
you know when we were driving out to the
site where that sacrifice happened the
cop didn't ask us where the turn was he
just turned like he already nailed like
you knew yeah so Peter Fonda was on to
them like from the beginning now I have
to say that so you know what I mean the
the wives are like trying to clean up
the [ __ ] because the when they try to
get away from the satanic cult they get
sucks they get stuck in a puddle and all
this other [ __ ] like the seitan is there
like the Satanists are like running
after them and like climbing all over
their RV and whatnot and they break the
windows and all this other stuff so then
the next day when they're cleaning up
they find this note with like all these
runes on it and there's like they it was
it was almost like an evil version of
like the Wiccan rede or like whatever
you do comes back to you three times but
they actually said nine times so like
whatever evil you did comes back to you
nine times or seven times I can't
remember but um so they were like well
what are these runes mean well let's go
to the like the library and check it
remember when he had to do that yeah
like get the library so they go to the
library and they try to take out all
these books about the Satanic runes and
stuff and then the librarians like well
you can't take those because they're
reference records or whatever I was
always trying to take the reference
books when I was a kid I was - yeah I
know you're like what the [ __ ] is the
best book in here I know they wouldn't
let you take the reference book yeah but
yeah so so the the minute the woman says
that Loretta Swit is totally like oh
yeah we're totally gonna put these back
wink wink wink and then she tells the
other wife she's like we're gonna put
him back right oh yeah totally we're in
so they steal them but um but what they
find out so they get the thing it's like
okay well these people are Satanists and
they're following us and everything so
so they start going from like town
like little town to little town now
there are V is kind of [ __ ] up because
the Satanists were jumping on their [ __ ]
and like break and everything so they
have to stop at this other gas station
they don't I don't think they super
specify like how far away it is but you
can tell when they stopped at this gas
station because I think it's one that
the cop recommended and they stopped
there and they're just like hey can you
fix this on the other and I'm like that
that dudes just gonna cut their brake
lines as enable and he does but and and
then like they keep going like because
they know how to like fix the RV
themselves so they like they do that
like farther down the line but I don't
know how far they're going because
eventually they almost get to Amarillo
so I don't know how far it was from and
I don't know how far to I'm not from
Texas I don't know how far it is from
Santonio to San Antonio daren't Amarillo
but they're driving and they keep going
through these little towns and like
everybody in these [ __ ] towns is the
saving that yeah when this is going on I
was asking Jenni I was like well how big
is this is this Satanist college
everybody know seemed like it was going
on for a long time so well they hadn't
been driving it was the same day they
were driving a more than okay it wasn't
like a long like it was only a few miles
like I said because their RV kept
getting [ __ ] up so they kept having to
stop and then like they'd stop in a town
and go in like this scary like
Leatherface lookin store it's like hey
can you you can we use your phone and
they're like yeah sure and then they'd
use the phone and it didn't work they'd
be like oh yeah the lines have been down
because some storm from up north
sorry about that it's been down for like
a month or whatever I'm like everybody
is [ __ ] in or it's like Rosemary's
Baby now in this in this let's get the
[ __ ] out of Dodge phase of this movie it
starts to get it starts to get a lot
like Mad Max 1 if you ask me oh yeah max
now the course is it's almost impossible
to beat Mad Max well yes
but there was a lot of like vehicle
action there on time yeah yeah there Ram
in the back of the yeah because they get
chased by the Satanists like it's in
these trucks and they're all because so
they're like coming in there trying to
knock the RV off the road and Peter
fawned is up there with us because they
stop and buy guns there
they're RAM in the back of the RV and
crushing the motorcycles they're getting
on top of the RV they're trying to get
inside and I was like man they're really
trying to do what
Mad Max one did I think I don't know
which movie was first but you know I
appreciated the effort yeah it wasn't
anywhere near as cool as Mad Max well no
but not a lot yeah but we're talking
about an American movie Matt the Mad Max
series was just Australia at its best
yeah they're just proven that they were
crazier than [ __ ] yeah I mean the only
one I don't totally love is Thunderdome
and that's of course a Hollywood movie
but the Australian ones are [ __ ]
great yeah yeah great even I love
Australian a fury road yeah fury road
was [ __ ] face yuria road was actually
actually shot - the one like my top 10
movie I can watch that over and over and
never get tired of it
right but I know they're [ __ ] there's
some CG in there they're mostly just
erasing the safety harnesses and racing
tire tracks really not a lot I saw the
behind-the-scenes [ __ ] and it's that's
really not that's pretty much all they
did if you guys haven't seen a badass
[ __ ] flick or any of the [ __ ] Mad
Max movies see Mad Max 2 also known as
the road warrior yeah that movie right
there is a [ __ ] bad-ass flick and all
those accidents and car wrecks and all
those stunts are real yeah those dudes
got busted up yeah broken legs did a
motorcycle stunts an excellent movie and
like I said so that's what I like about
that's why if if I had to choose between
these these two movies like if I had to
say which one is a better movie I would
probably pick this one because it has
more of that Mad Max kind of chase feel
to it because it's essentially it's a
road movie it's these two couples in an
RV and they're trying to get away from
the Satanist and they're mostly driving
and there's really good scenes of like
you know distinctness will be in the
trucks or whatever and they're trying to
run the RV out there and the cars get
all [ __ ] up and you
you know they try to do roadblocks and
all this other stuff so it's like got a
really good tense kind of action to it
because it's just like a chase film like
pretty much through Google I think I
would agree that technically and
technically I'd probably say that this
movie's better than the car yeah but I
like I like the I like the [ __ ]
obvious
yes Dalton I think I'm saying har
yeah and I think it had a lot to do with
the soundtrack yeah and Roland yeah and
just the way that movie went
it's a conventional movie of the time
and in a way that might help me enjoy it
a little bit better it's there's no
there wasn't any really surprises in it
it's just like yeah gave me exactly what
I thought yeah I mean yeah the lines of
like Amityville Horror he knows yes if
we're watching a movie called the car
that's about a satanic car and it gives
from the 70s then that's about what you
expect that what you're expecting to
happen and so I I like that I'm gonna
give it to that one yeah yeah although
it has an expiry yeah I have to say and
like I said this is spoiler alert so if
you don't want to know the ending of
these movies then well I think we
already spoiled anything in the car but
if you don't want to if you don't want
to know the ending of race with the
devil just skip over like five minutes
or something like that but the car has a
marginally happy ending in that I mean a
lot of people died including James
Roland's girlfriend who got smushed by
the car like crashing through her house
like six feet off the ground which is
amazing but you know they sort of
defeated the car in the end in the sense
that it's implied that they like got it
out of their town or whatever even
though at the end you see that it's
still alive and it's still going now
race with the devil does not really have
a happy ending I mean they don't really
show what happens but what happens is
that you know as they're kind of going
along with they're realizing they're
trying to get to Amarillo so they can
like which is a real city I guess that's
like the next big city on their route
and they're trying to get there and get
the blood to the you know lab
or whatever and like report it to the
police because obviously everyone behind
them as Satanists
so they're trying to get there but when
they stop at this one particular place
you know and they think oh we almost
made it like we can hear a radio station
from Amarillo so we're almost there and
then all of a sudden the cult catches up
with them you know there's flames around
the you know there's a big like fire
ring like around their RV and like all
the Satanists come out that and you can
see like everybody that has been like
that weird couple that came in their RV
and like looked into all their [ __ ] and
like took them out to this horrible
country-western bar that I would never
step foot in front I'm like yeah that's
how all right you should have known but
yeah it's like they're all getting in
fights and whatnot but so those people
to cop like everybody comes out and
they're just like oh they're all
Satanists and you assume they're gonna
get killed because what the [ __ ] are
they gonna do it's like they have two
rifles but they're gonna run out of ammo
before they shoot all the sameness so
you assume that the two couples get
sacrificed by the sameness I mean that's
pretty much what I thought was the end
of that so that actually has like a sad
ending also a dog gets killed yeah yeah
it does the door actually that upset me
probably more than it should have and
you know what I mean it's it's funny
because I can watch horror movies where
people get killed all day long and I
don't it's not that I don't care it's
just kind of like oh a person got killed
but man you killed a dog or cat in a
movie I am just like I'm just like why
why did you do that I'm gonna give it to
the car yeah I'm gonna give it to the
car like the tone of the movie it
delivered like you said if you want to
see a car if you want to see a movie
about a satanic car a 70s flick it
delivers yeah it's like no Christie and
gives you everything that your ex but
and and and it and the ending and
everything this way it ended I'm like
yeah there you go
yeah they blew their [ __ ] up there you
go and then you know the wife-beater I
just liked the I liked the [ __ ] tone
of that movie we didn't go into the wife
beater thing
[Laughter]
dude in that movie in the car who was
beating his wife yeah but it all turned
out okay because he had dynamite and
that's what the cops do they let him out
of juice right that's right that's right
it was it 70s morality although I have
to say I kind of like even though he
kind of got redeemed at the end I did
like the way they treated like his wife
because she you know she gets brought
into the police station because she's
all her faces all over yeah and he's
trying to help her you know I mean he's
like please will you please use all the
time well yeah cuz she was afraid that
he would kill her because that's what
happened but yeah so I liked that they
did that yeah but so that had a sort of
the car has more of a marginally happy
ending because like I said you you feel
like they defeated it at least
temporarily I think what was supposed to
happen race with the devil does not have
a happy ending I think what was supposed
to happen with the wife-beater character
is that because he had the dynamite and
he went out there and fought the devil
car all right and put his ass on the
line that that was the atonement yeah
you know I think I think we were
supposed to believe that that he was
just gonna go turned over a new leaf
that he's now a good guy yeah but that's
the way those movies worked yeah sure
you know that's why there's nobody's
working yeah like I said and race with
the devil there's really no anything I
mean it kind of comes it's it's more
realistic in the sense that look if
everyone's a Satanist in every [ __ ]
town leading up to Amarillo and all you
have is like a year RV and like two
rifles and there's like these Satanists
are chasing you and they're intent on
killing you because you saw their
sacrifice or whatever then they're
probably gonna get you in the end and
they do and like I said I was very upset
about the the dog's name was ginger by
the way what about it don't know I'm
just saying they're real dumb it was a
real bone you know that there I don't
know if you know this but there is a
whole website called does the dog die
dot-com that they review every single
movie and they don't tell you if there's
a dog that gets killed
because people get upset by this dog
didn't die I just the dog didn't die it
was not a real dog it did upset me it
upset me in the movie even though I'm
probably like even this dog actor is
probably like long dead because that's a
long time ago but it's still like really
upset baby and I'm a cat person I know
but is it I know it's just playing with
your emotions instead of playing with
your emotion it's funny that they can do
it with a dog or a cat but now what he
probably says a lot about me we can wrap
it up both of these movies are available
on shudder right and of course I'm not
plugging shudder shudder isn't paying us
shudder owes us so much [ __ ] money
cause all we do is talk about the boobs
around shutter shutter you can see chef
like seven bucks a buck and I know I
like it better than Netflix they're not
even seven dollars no is it six bucks
about four dollars you owe a shatter
it's four dollars on four dollars
although I think I might do because what
they do if you pay once a year and I
think it's forty seven dollars then
that's only like three nananana monster
so I actually might do an annual even
though five dollars a month is Italy and
every week they got new movies I think
it's actually going up a dollar so if
you want to get shudder you might want
to get it before the end of May because
I think their prices are going up no but
it's only going up a buck it's only
going up you're like $5.99 a month all
right I mean you know but yeah like I
said check these two out if you like
Satanic movies from the 70s which I do I
love that [ __ ] if you like vehicular
type of movies you know car chase seven
movies you'll like that - probably race
with the devil better but you know I'm
gonna fight over you're not I'm gonna
fight over I'm gonna say the car was
better the car was kind of like the
Satanic version of Jaws yeah that's yeah
it's just simple it was simpler it was
more morbid like a turret it was
directing to the point yeah I was just
saying I'd like to race with the devil
better because it was more it was more
like tension and it was more like the
whole paranoia thing because when
everyone was in on it
what I liked about you freaks me out
what I liked about that one is that it
had elements of Mad Backson mm-hmm so
I'm gonna give it that it was good
that's you they [ __ ] up a lot of it's
good maybe had I saw earlier when I was
younger maybe I would have had
like a great affinity for it yeah but
you know I can go you know I've seen a
car a long time ago so I were already
kind of favored it holy [ __ ] I just
remembered the name of that [ __ ]
William Shatner movie The Devil's rain
oh yeah that's right god [ __ ] damn it
it took me the whole show to remember
the name look we got us Annette again
we'll do a show on that one too like I
said you know there's not this probably
the only movie in the history of movies
that have a cat in a goat and Anton
LaVey isn't it to you that's right even
he's just like in the background man
it's all the very would be in anything
back in the seventies he's like yeah
I'll be a consultant on your movie put
me in that [ __ ] you's a [ __ ] but that's
that's what you would do so yeah we'll
have to do the devil's right too but
yeah go check out these two movies the
car and what's he know I know I've just
my brains not working I've been working
all day
all right so that'll do it for this
movie retrospective hope you enjoyed it
remember if you liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you would like to financially support
the show would be much appreciated you
can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there is a little button in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation
remember that our movie retrospectives
come out every Friday our regular
episodes come out every Tuesday and our
13 o'clock matinee which is three new
movies in the theater comes out every
Sunday so check them out if you haven't
already and that will do it for this
episode we will see you next time bye